hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over round nine
from the 2021 candice tournament race to
see who plays magnus carlson
for the world championship our
competitors white's gonna be played by
anish giri i don't know if there's
anyone in the tournament that would want
to face magnus carlsen
in the world championship more than a
niche but he's going to be playing the
white pieces black's going to be played
by wang
both these players are in the middle of
the pack and with a win
both of these players would catapult
themselves to a tie
four seconds this is a massive game for
both of these players and he starts out
with pawn to d4
knight to f6 pawn c4
pawnee six and then knight to f3 getting
into the catalan opening after g3
preparing to
be encountered the bishop here to uh g2
white's really looking to control the
light diagonal here
and then eventually if he wants to bring
his knight here to e5
uh to activate the light squared bishop
he can as well definitely an approach
that you'll see sometimes after pawn d4
and pawn here to c4 as well and then
bishop to e7
we see bishop to g2 castle on the kings
side for both of these players and then
pawn
takes on c4
queen here to c2 attacking the pawn and
we see pawn a6 from wing and usually
don't see them try to hold on to the
pawn on a c4
it's just so difficult and you end up
blowing up your structure after pawns at
e4
very difficult to hold on let's say they
play pawn a6
you know you capture here they can't
really recapture you just take up here
on
a8 so decides let's not push forward
here with b5 first instead let's go
ahead and play
pawn to a6 you know if white doesn't
recognize that the threat can come at
some point here with
b5 maybe easier to defend this uh but we
do see
immediately the push forward here with
a4
so anish already prepared for
controlling this b5 square so that he
can eventually just go ahead and take
this c4 square bishop here to
d7 just activating also attacking this
pawn this pawn is pretty well defended
by the queen and the rook from
white queen decides to go ahead and take
here on c4
also still defending uh this pawn all of
a sudden bishop here to
c6 so we said you know one of the
reasons you play the catalan is because
you want to control this light square
diagonal from white here
and wang decides hey from black
standpoint i want to go ahead and
counter attack
this light square diagonal as well so
there's definitely going to be an attack
going on here bishop to f4
from white and then bishop to d6 now
if you're watching this live it really
looks like the bishop is going to take
here on d6
this was definitely the move i expected
you almost
never expect them to just allow you to
take here on f4 because it really blows
up
what you would think is a pawn structure
here that's pretty solid with
f2 g3 and h2
but white said yeah we're going to go
ahead and just develop the rest of our
pieces here with knight to c3
black wasted no time taking here on f4
and then recapture on f4 now not all's
lost as falls
as far as the pawn structure after pawn
two a
five which is really clearly setting up
the knight coming here to a6 and then a
great outpost
here on b4 because white's not really
threatening here on
b4 right now but you can see the knight
can't come here to
c6 wants to keep his queen open
with this semi-open file on the d-file
so
really the next logical move is to bring
the knight here to a6
and then wants to come here to b4 since
the
c5 square is being defended
and attacked by this pawn here on d4 but
after pawn to e3 you can see there's a
there's a pawn here on e3 uh that's
solidified it has protection by this
pawn on f2 but also protects both of
these pawns here on
d4 and f4 so
the king definitely has less safety in
front of him but he does have the bishop
here and
as long as he maneuvers correctly anish
definitely should be
in a pretty good spot with a lot of
pawns in the center of the board
so black definitely has to be aware of
that there's a reason
that anish decided to give up the bishop
here
and have a solid pawn structure in the
center so black definitely has to be
aware
of anisha's plans play continues
as we would expect with knight to a6 the
knight up here to e5
activating this bishop black immediately
just takes the bishop here
uh which is kind of what we expected
with the bishop coming here to c6 did
not
really want to play against that bishop
on g2
controlling the entire light square
diagonal
and so there is an exchange king takes
here on g2
you would expect with this setup that
the king might come back
to h1 or g1 because right now it is
completely out in the open now the the
queen would have to come over here to
attack that
both of the bishops from black as far as
white as well
but really black they are off the board
so as far as any shenanigans on this
light square diagonal to attack the king
that's not going to happen
is going to be some time before the
rooks really attack
over here on the king's side as well
pawn to
c6 opening up another avenue for the
queen to get involved into the game also
preparing if the palm wants to push here
on
the b file pawn here to h3 also allows
for another place that the king can come
here to
h2 as well also has another outpost if
the knight wants to come back here
to uh g4 so setting up a lot of stuff
from white's perspective
queen comes over here to b6 queen comes
back here to e2 preparing if he wants to
come over here to the king side of the
board
c5 we see rook over here to d1 makes
sense as well if you want to bring your
rook to
d1 as well i think both of those are
completely fine but decides to go and
bring his f rook over here to a d1
there's an exchange in the center of the
board definitely want to be taking here
with your rook it blows up your pawn
structure here now you have double pawns
on the f file
and you have an isolated pawn here on
the d file definitely not what you're
looking for
takes with his rook here on d4 rook over
here to d8 says yeah let's go and
exchange some material here on
the d8 square work over here to d1
attacking the queen
and the queen comes back over here to a8
so you can see on the next move the pawn
could move wherever he wants to
b5 b6 discovered attack on the king
uh so anish says yeah we're not going to
be messing with that i'm going to go
ahead and bring my king back here to g1
because i don't want you to have any
shenanigans on the board here
knight to b4 expected it at some point
didn't know exactly when it was come
but it does come now with a great little
outpost for
this knight here and then the queen
comes up here to
b5 if we look at both sides equal in
material but
where is both sides going to really
attack from white's standpoint
these pawns over here are the most
logical
option this pawn is not protected right
now
except by the queen and so if you kind
of double up on this pawn that's
definitely one option here
this pawn here on b7 is protected by the
queen if you can kind of hold down
black to just protecting mode that's
definitely not a bad thing from black's
perspective
maybe you want to attack this pawn
structure here on the e and f files or
potentially this pawn here on
b2 at some point but definitely looks
like with
the queen here on a b5 white has a
slightly upper hand as far as the
initiative
attacking these pawn structures my guess
at some point it kind of looks like
these knights will start to exchange off
the board
and then we may have an in-game of who
is better with their pawn structures
there may be a major piece
as well we just have to see here knight
to
d5 going from one outpost on b4 over to
another outpost here on d
d5 blocking off this rook here on d1
from getting involved into the game we
do see an exchange here
and then rook over here to c1 says okay
i can't really kick
this knight away and so if i wanted to
get involved into the game
rook here to c1 is the most logical
option
pawn here to h6 just preparing for an
option if the king ever does need to
move for any reason uh queen two and d7
so really trying to attack a lot of the
squares
uh and this is not only attacking this
pawn here on b7 but also the weeknd
square here on f7
this knight is attacking it so yes it's
defended right now by the rook
and the king here but definitely
something to keep in mind
what white's preparing for can always
bring his rook here to c7 at some point
if he can get this rook on d5 to move
away
first we do see black play knight to f6
attacking the queen queen comes back
here to d6
and then pawn to g6
just another uh move as far as where the
king can come to
so definitely trying to prepare for an
attack that an hdre has
then we play pawn to b3
from a niche and then pawn to h5 on
from black standpoint king h2
king to a g7 king here to
d4 so you can see both sides really just
trying to
improve their position a little bit take
away some of the critical squares that
their opponent wants to go to
and see if they can make something of
this game
now wayne plays rook to d8 attacking the
queen queen comes back here to
b2 then after queen to b8
we see pawn to b4
and this is starting to push on the
queen type with a really really strong
attack
you can't really play something like
pawn to b6 to protect this pawn
because then that just loses to knight
to c6
forking both the queen and the rook here
so really you almost have to take it
seems like i mean you could play
queen over here and try to protect the
pawn here but it seems like the best
move is pawn to b4
and what i think is the best move up
into this point is from manish giri and
he plays the move rook
to c4 yes he could absolutely take with
his queen right away but he recognizes
the better move
is to play rook to c4 and then take the
pawn here on
b4 and that sets up for a pretty strong
attack
coming up here to the b pawn from
black because you know black would
really like to defend that with
something like knight
or rook 2 d7 but that's defended by this
knight here on e5 this is an amazing
outpost that white has here and very
difficult for black to deal with so
uh decides yeah okay i don't i don't
just want to make it easy for you but
it's still
pretty easy after rook two b4 this pawn
is going to fall
this pawn over here on a4 is pretty
protected here
and this pawn up here on b7 is
eventually going to fall now queen 2a7
says
yeah if you want to go ahead and take
that's fine i'm going to go ahead and
take your pawn over here
uh anishkiri looks at and says actually
yeah i'm going to go ahead and allow you
to do that because he doesn't have to he
could take with his queen if he wanted
to
there are options but decides to go
ahead and take with his rook and after
queen takes here on a4
we see rook up here to b7 but now all of
a sudden the rook
and the knight here are attacking this
pawn on f7
that was more than enough to go ahead
and exchange the pawns over here on at
the queen side because
this king over here on h2 is pretty well
defended
there's not much material that can get
involved anytime
quickly where white has an immediate
threat here on
the f7 square so queen comes back here
to e8
and this is exactly why it's playing is
get black in defense mode as long as
they're not attacking
white can just slowly and surely improve
the position and eventually
black will fall
white continues with the attack rook 2
a7 preparing to bring the queen up here
to
b7 aiming all the material on this f7
square
rook down to d5 that's not what the game
is about queen 2
b7 knight 2 e4 everything's just moving
away from f7
and so that's just not going to work so
knight takes on f7 and this is going to
be
good game black just realizes that
there's nothing really that can be done
here
after the knight moves there's a
discovered attack on the king here if we
start to look at some of the options
you know king 2 f8 gonna be similar to
g8 they all lose with
you know let's say knight to d6
attacking
the queen uh well then you just have
queen over here to d7
uh there's it's just all going to be
lost here if we come back and say
what if they don't come to uh f8
well then it's just easy to check the
opponents
with knight to h6 here
and then it's pretty easy to just bring
the queen over and checkmate the
opponents you could
have king to uh f8 here
uh and then just king two g7 and this is
going to be checkmate so that would be a
pretty easy loss
and then you could even if you wanted to
get the king involved into the game
king 2 f6 well now you just play
queen 2 b2 attacking the king no good
square the knight here on f7 is still
protected by the rook
if they play something like pawn to e5
well then just the queen comes back here
to
the sixth rank here attacking the king
it's very difficult to hold on to
everything that's going on here
uh at the end of the day it is going to
fall like the queen can't take here
because that's just going to be
checkmate here so at the end of the day
uh wang hao decides to go ahead and
resign anish geary
all of a sudden catapulting himself into
second place there's a big tie going on
he's only half a point behind first
place
and we've got many games left so
congratulations to him i know this
tournament a lot
it would be really fun especially in the
twitter realm
to watch him and magnus carlson banter
back and forth
leading up into the tournament uh in
november for the world championship
so i think that would be super fun if he
won uh definitely cheering for a few of
these guys to have a good run in the
candidates tournament thank you so much
for watching
round number nine hopefully you guys
enjoyed it and i will see you tomorrow
for round number 10.